welcome to another edition of beginner
breakdown I am Mike comer after a long
hiatus due to the very successful
Sinquefield Cup it had a price went up
three hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars and the winner
Fabiana Carano got a hundred thousand
dollars we will not be going over any of
their games today because I didn't even
understand half the stuff that was going
on but today we got some simpler games
from a simpler man we have a game that I
played with the white pieces against
amateur Tim Bauer okay and I had the
white pieces all right so I start out
pawn to e4 you're following along Jared
good
all right pun to e4 all right and now
black plays Knight to c6 all right so
I've been telling you guys if if they're
not attacking this a pawn or didn't play
like 'if I've re4 our c5 or 'if I've to
attack this d4 square that you know
maybe we should go ahead and play d4 in
this position okay but if we play d4 in
this position what move do you think
blacks going to play here B five okay if
they play e5 here which is not the main
line you can play d5 and then you're
looking pretty cool you know what the
main move in this position is f5 okay f5
f5 if they play F I'll probably just
take it I feel pretty good because I'm
threatening Queen to h5 check and like
if you play this move look at Queen to
h5 check g6 pawn takes pawn takes
checkmate so yeah
if you've been following our lectures
you don't really want to move that
f-pawn f6 is really bad but f5 can be
just as harmful sometimes alright so we
try f5 and E 5
it's got happy D 5 right it's gotta be T
5 good and d50 if we take Queen takes if
we like play Knight to c3 to shew the
Queen away guess what we just lost our
pawn ok so very interesting ok so so now
he just played Knight to c6 the last
thing we want him to do is to play d5
here okay so what move can we make to
prevent d5 what you thought why don't
you come up so you can see right yeah
awesome say hi to the camera
alright you vines in the class now we
know we got a fearsome foursome here ok
alright so let's make a move that
prevents black from playing d5 without
serious repercussions as in losing the
point excellent ok Knight to c3 all
right we don't want to play d5 okay so
he's like I wanna play d5 ok so he plays
d6 preparing d5 but then we're like okay
I know you want to play d5 and I still
don't want to let you play d5 so what
moves should we make
yeah just Bishop to c4 see we're getting
our pieces minor pieces the bishops of
the Knights off the back row with a
purpose we're not just the wool them out
they're just like oh I'm developing I'm
developing ok we're actually fighting
for squares control of this d5 square ok
now it's like I really want to play d5
let me play d5 already so I plays Knight
up 6 ok all right so now it's like
geez this pawns doing everything you can
to stop d5 this bishops doing everything
you can to stop d5 and so was the knight
so somebody's got to get in there
because if we play like Knight f3 or
something random he can just play d5
right and we don't want them to play d5
so what move could we possibly do we got
to get another piece in there to stop d5
any ideas Yvon III well III is illegal
but d3 if you play d3 unfortunately he
can play d5 then and you see he's got
one two three defenders and we only got
one to say it one work he's got just as
many defenders as we have attacker so
he's he's asus okay so we need one more
one more guy all right Queen f3 it won't
even let you it's like that's like okay
yeah all right Queen f3 I was thinking
about it I was thinking about it but now
fork who can see a fork oh I will take
that as 95
all right so 95 oh man I'm fourth that's
not cool
Knight to e2 unfortunately still lets
them play d5 but so you're on the way
trick with the Queen but Queen to e2
because now if you plays d5 watch what
happens
pawn takes oh I can't take like that and
now he's he's mad because this point is
in an absolute pin okay he can't move
off the file he could play e5 if you
wanted in fact I would make him play e5
because he touched it alright you touch
the pun you got to move it alright so
you got to play e5
and then we would attack but that's
beside the point okay so Queen to e2
alright so now he attacks so he doesn't
play d5 because he can't alright because
I would just take it for free so he
plays Knight to d4 attacking my Queen
okay so my Queens attacked and what else
is he attacking besides my queen Knight
takes C to check fork yeah
alright scary so so it should be a
little baby and go back to d1 no that's
not fun no no no so Queen to d3 attack
the knight okay alright so so now he
develops his bishop with a purpose
protecting my knight all right
so let's just get rid of this Knight
okay so he gets the check in Queen takes
f3 or okay all right so now can he play
d5 in this position no he still can't
because we got one two three four guys
on this and he's only got three so after
all this hard work he still can't play
d5 alright so look what move he makes
all right boom d6 a puny move by a puny
man d6 I hate so we prevented d5 and we
won the opening okay so we race is all
right so now we play Knight a4 trade
this night for his Bishop get rid of his
Bishop pair he decides not to move it
back
he plays Queen to e7 so we just take it
right and now we give him double pawns
all right double pawns are weaker than
normal pawns for obvious reasons okay so
now we Castle so it's moved time we're
doing pretty good we give them double
pawns we're castled it's impossible for
him to play d5 so we're
we're good so so he plays d5 because he
wants to get his Bishop active okay so
we want to get our Bishop active so do
you think we should play b3 or d3 or
does it even matter
b3 so we play b3 our bishop would go on
to a b2 I decide with d3 I can pin the
night so that's why I choose d3 but
you've got to get this Bishop out of
there okay all right feel free to come
in take a seat
and okay so now tune plays Bishop to e6
here okay so he wants to trade bishops
here okay so if you look at his pawns
here do they look pretty good to anybody
no so should I let Tim do take my bishop
and make my pawns look like that no no
obviously not okay so what move should I
make then if I don't want my pawns
looking like his weak pawns okay so so
Jarrod suggests Bishop to b3 okay so
with Bishop to b3 let's assume he comes
down and takes it and then we take with
our a pawn okay so now we've opened up
the a file and our work is looking
pretty good but what move could black
make to neutralize the strength of this
rook here because this rook looks pretty
pretty good pretty active but there's a
very simple move by black to just like
it it doesn't really matter that you're
Brooks on the a file yeah just play a
six and then this rook doesn't look as
strong
anymore and look at our ponds do they
look very strong no we'd rather have
them all just you know nice connected
and together instead of doubled okay so
what moves should we play as white in
this position yes you vine yeah just
take the bishop okay because we don't
want you know our pawns that you be
messed up when they don't have to be
okay we'll have them all nice and
connected okay look at that one big pawn
island okay so we're looking pretty good
here so we bring our Bishop out to
attack the knight and now he attacks it
so now we capture the night and we gets
double ponds now okay but these double
pawns aren't as bad as these double
pawns because now black has the G file
open okay and our King our nine billion
dollar point piece okay is sitting on
the G file so it's kind of scary that
this rooks coming in and threatening the
G file okay so we just have to keep an
eye on that okay all right cool Queen to
e3 a anybody tell me why I probably made
that move I'm attacking two pawns right
fork yeah but this one's already
protected so all he has to do is protect
this that is not well I guess it is a
tactic because it was a fork but but
it's pretty easy for him to uh to stop
this
all he has to do is move his Queen so
now he made a dual-purpose move here
with this Queen and that's good he had
protected the pawn and now he's
attacking a pawn but as you'll see with
my next move f4 I totally ignored his
threat because if he takes here
this is very very dangerous for your
queen to be taking this pawn not just in
this variation but just in general
because what move do you think I'm going
to make for a follow up here well I'm
actually I probably would play Queen
takes but but an idea is I'll move my
rook here you'll take and then I'll get
my rook up here and I'll be causing some
havoc for you up there okay so just
watch out when you take a beep on with
your queen
it could be poisoned okay so I play f4
I'm trying to open some lines for my
rooks
like that's one downfall of having all
your pawns all nice in a row is there's
no open files for your rooks to play and
they have to get out because look at my
rooks they're really not doing much
right so I have to create open lines for
them to play okay so f4 he wisely
doesn't take it
taking would be a catastrophe for him
because after I take look how active my
queen is okay and look how bad his pawns
are okay so he ignores it and he he gets
his rook on an open file on this G line
okay the G file so he's on the same lane
as my King putting this pawn in a pin
see I could never capture anything on h3
or f3 with this pawn because it's in a
pin it's protecting my king all right so
so I play f5 and kind of neutralize the
threat there okay so he brings his pawn
out of danger with h5 so now I'm looking
for ideas so now I decide I'm going to
play work to b1 and not let his Queen
come down and take my point okay
so black castles alright so a natural
move to follow up to rook to be one all
your moves should have some kind of a
rhythm and plan in place so a natural
follow-up from rook to be one would be
the move b4 okay I'm not afraid of pawn
takes because then I would take giving
him temporarily triple pawns when I
would take right back and this would be
a advantage endgame for white because
he's got this isolated pawns he's got
this set of double pawns and this set of
double pawns why I have one big point
island and then this pawn island this
isolated pawn okay so white would be I
have the advantage okay all right so
before he sees that and everybody knows
why Queen takes pawn was bad because the
rook would take it so he decides to be
kind of funny here and play rook to d4
okay so he's threatening my pawn okay so
I think I see a great move and hopefully
you guys think you see a great move too
but then we'll have to look a little
further so can anybody think what they
think is a good move here that I thought
was a good move
yes yes
okay so so so what briefly go over this
this is what Grand Master been Feingold
likes to say I'm too old for this stuff
okay he's paraphrasing a Danny Glover I
think okay it's like yes hey it's just
like come on it's like this is crazy
then take take take take who knows
what's going on I don't know what's
going on it's just craziness okay
there's a lot to calculate a lot of
trades and it's just like that yeah so I
play c3 okay so so this is when
psychology kind of comes into chess as
well okay like Jared you probably
thought c3 is a great move right
I think c3 is agreement like I like I
played c3 I lean back a little I'm like
I'm the best okay like it's close to
look what c3 did it attack this rook and
it protected this pawn so we can't play
rook takes pawn like he wants to now
okay so so my opponent like in the game
he's like oh man you're good I'm just
going to retreat back to d8 okay I give
a gold star to anybody who can find the
reputation to this move c3 because it
looks really good I thought it was good
I played it in the move that that's how
good I thought it was so what does a so
there's a tactic here if you look for
your captures and your checks you may be
able to find c3 this is why I say never
play f6 like all the time right never
play off six now obviously f6 wasn't
played in this game
but f4 was okay so notice that my king
is on this diagonal with the Queen rook
pawn and Queen and there's no F pawn
right right rook takes d3 all right so
now the Queen is under attack
everybody's like oh it looks like a free
rook looks like a free rook but then
what does black do to win the Queen yes
c4 check and now my queen is hanging and
it if I go anywhere to block it
it'll get captured make sense so don't
feel bad if you didn't find it I played
c3 and I thought I was the man okay and
luckily he did too because he went oh I
guess I just go back to d8 okay so so
but you got to look for tactics all the
time so now I have two players on this
pawn and he only has one defender so I
better capture it but I better get it
right how I capture it so I could
capture with the pawn or with the Queen
what happens if I take it with the Queen
what's the downside of capturing this
with the Queen okay okay good so you so
you calculated one move okay so let's
just calculate two moves now
okay I would be I would be so just just
look a little more so you see Queen
takes Queen check so now what's White's
response going to be alright and now
everybody hold on tight and now what
would Black's next move be then just
look a little bit deeper in the position
alright just look for your captures and
your checks everybody hang tight so is
there anything that black can capture in
this position d3 yeah and then that
would be this would look pretty good and
then we try to just envision that just
just think a little bit more and then
that would be pretty bad for what you
see this point is really weak these
pawns are just horrible and this point
ain't nothing to brag about either okay
so white would be going down okay so so
after your rook to DA now we know hey we
don't want to take with the Queen Earl's
that bad stuff will happen so by default
we have to take with the pawn all right
so now you place Queen to a six fork so
is the Z oh how the queen of mobile
Queen and open board you want to be
attacking more than one thing okay get
the most bang for your buck out of moves
so he's attacking this pawn and this
pawn I can't save them both I wish I
could but I can't so I gotta let one go
so should I let that pawn go yeah no
yeah should see it see how but different
it looks I'd rather I'd rather say at
this point because he's holding
everything together yes
all right if I play Queen to d2 so the
funny thing was is that he was my one
and only defender on d3 and he still is
so I didn't add anybody to protecting d3
you see what I'm saying so I need
anybody need like my rook to jump like
boom boom like a knight okay and protect
both but he can't so he can just do this
and then hope hope really hard that he
doesn't take this pawn and I guess all
my hoping paid off okay so so he plays
King to b8 why I don't know okay
so now I can play rook up and protect
this pawn
okay he really should have taken his
pawn when he had the chance
all right so now he plays c6 so now I
bring my rook over protect the pawn
again so now he attacks this pawn so
there's a really cool way I can defend
this pawn d4 ya see the Queen protects
it okay so when somebody pushes a pawn
and no this is a radical idea okay it
looks like he's just pushing it to take
my pawn right to capture what other move
is this pawn threatening to make besides
pawn takes e5 yes
right okay yes but 65 yes yes a lot of
people get in the mindset close mind
said that he's just he played Z
forwarded just to take my pawn that's
all he's trying to do yes okay okay is
he threatening anything else but yes I
see what all right so he's threatening
pawn takes e5 true is he threatening
anything else
d5 yes you always have to look just
because they played a pawn move even if
it's attacking something they may have
played it for an ulterior motive they
may have played it the push and push and
push okay so always keep that in the
back of your head because a lot of
people think oh he's just but look let's
just say he played a six or something
okay all right first of all pawn takes
true it opens this file up okay but take
a look at this now blacks pawns look
great right they're not they're not
doubled and look at my pawns without
that D pawn these pawns look like mush
huh not too good all right so after
Queen to c7 now instead of taking I push
the pawn and if he takes what she does I
just created a passed pawn a passed pawn
is a pawn that no pawns can get in front
of or on adjacent files where they can
capture them so it's passed only up now
one of his other pieces like a king
rook Knight have to get behind it to
stop it okay obviously doesn't want to
do that
okay so now I got past one but true he's
got a passed pawn too but mine looked a
lot more dangerous than his all right so
now he wants a
King to come over and try to stop these
puns good luck okay all right so pass
pawns are meant to be pushed all right
when you have passed pawns get them
going don't want to just hold them on
forever let's get them going okay Queen
ac6 so very interesting he's aiming at
g2 okay so if I move my rook
it could be danger it could be lights
out for me okay
all right this rook is the only guy
stopping checkmate here so what's a
funny move I can make with this rook
here I could play there but that's not
very funny
what correct it c5 right that's kind of
funny right the d5 alright so the basic
he puts the rook in a pin okay I only
did it because he did it earlier and I
kind of saw it's kind of like homage to
him okay so rook up there so now rook
attacks the pawn so I should really
protect that pawn but I get too
preoccupied with something else so I
play rook here just over protecting the
checkmate now okay so he takes it okay
but now I get a tactic it's not a good
tactic but it is a tactic what tactic
can I play here that coincides with the
move rook takes f5
Queen age 3 pin very good absolute pen
so what's the only move blacks should
even consider playing in this position
right yeah and no everything else loses
okay going to d7 breaks the pin and
defends the rook awesome alright alright
so now I have to watch out for moves
like rook to f1 check eventually not
right now though
but eventually I should be scared I
should be thinking about that though
right now I should know oh my God if he
plays rook to f1 check he can trade
Queens or something so I better keep
this G pawn around okay or something
alright so I just bring my work over
there whatever alright so he plays rook
to g8 now if I wasn't thinking about
rook to f1 check earlier I might not
have saw oh my god he's threatening this
now what's so great about if I play a
four or something what's so good about
rook to f1 check here nothing nothing
why doesn't this work for our four black
because King takes and I'm no longer in
the pin yay so I don't care so I just
play c4 all right now he's like I'm
going to make it care about that or a
rook to g5 alright so now things are
getting exciting
alright so I swing my Queen over I get
out of all this shenanigans and I'm
threatening this pawn but look he's got
a queen here alright so King to b8 never
a good idea to walk into a file
with that all your opponent's major
pieces are on because now what did you
just do to this pawn you pinned it yeah
you just pinned it and what do we do to
pin pieces yes okay good job you vine
yeah we attack them so let's do it
you're ready to attack the Queen attack
the pin piece c6 all right so now we
sacrifice the pawn and now how do we
finish black off here ye seven the only
way to stop rook up so let's get a queen
while we can so takes check alright so
now we've got to be really careful here
believing in that for white because
black has some tricks of his own what if
we just say hey let's double our Brooks
on the D file that looks like a natural
move right
what would black do even though he's
down a whole rook here
how would he just humiliate white here
yes
Queen to c5 check excellent okay because
if we retreat our King to h1 back row
checkmate very good if we play rook here
Queen takes and then we're done and so
the best move for white actually is rook
here and now he's got a passed pawn and
now he's winning all of a sudden okay so
we got to be really careful even though
we're up a lot of material it's no time
to relax okay so so luckily instead of
playing that rook over we brought our
book down to protect okay so now Queen
to c5 really doesn't have the same bite
Queen to c5 check we don't want to go to
h1 because we'll still get back where
checkmated but we're going to swing our
rook over and we'll be fine okay so so
after E for now let's try to finish them
off okay because because I know we're up
but we got to get this thing going we
got to checkmate them so so the only
check for white g3 right so we might as
well play it so he retreats back to c8
what's a check we see for weight again
anybody you've on
Queen Angie hey Jack don't be too
excited about it okay you're just trying
to secure a win here all right King to
c7 yeah Oh No
Queen to DA yeah when you get a check
when you see a checkmate go for it
okay and that would be a checkmate all
right
we got time for one more quick game and
it's a it's a doozy that's for sure okay
so this was played in our Monday night
series Neil against Greg Neil had the
white pieces okay and now we'll see once
again where a pawn moves and he might
just want to advance it so keep it in
mind okay all right so pawn to e4 black
plays ePHI all right so Knight f3
attacks the pawn nice e6 protects that
everybody should should know this basic
opening Bishop the c4 so black decides
he's going to play Queen to e7 okay so
that's not recommended so Knight to c3
all right so now it gets Knight up six
and all right so after white castles d6
okay so now the infamous d4 so he's
threatening pawn takes but also possibly
d5 okay so what do you think the worst
move for black is in this position
well there's a couple but what's a
really bad move like Knight takes I mean
that's bad woods yep
Queen to e6 yeah that's pretty bad
Austen well yeah critics brought back
because a bishop would take but also
Bishop to e6 is pretty bad you never
want to put your minor pieces you know
on the same rank right next to you know
one file apart because what does that
allow now the fork yet upon for d5 okay
it's like come on haven't just seen this
before it's not cool to be pawn for it
because it's so easily avoidable if
you're still getting pawned for it after
you played 200 games of chess should
really think about this okay I think if
you ask yourself why do I keep getting
pawn for just like no think about it
okay alright so he's like I tricked you
actually put the move Knight a5 okay so
so this is what you want to do when
you're you're in a bind like black was
you want to try to create a threat
greater or equal to your opponent's okay
and he did write my minor piece were
under attack so I'm going to attack one
of your minor pieces okay so should
why'd you say well alright well just
take and take and check and then
whatever we're even or should we be more
ambitious hopefully we want to be more
ambitious right okay goo could check the
King let's see if that works
see 600 now our Bishop is really under
attack all right he could be even
funnier well well maybe you could be
even funnier
and just play Bishop back and now pulls
this pieces are you know out of that
vicious pawn fork but good try because
we that we created a threat you know
greater as well but he was able to get
out of it okay
but Bishop to b5 if we really dig in
deep it might still be okay so does
anybody have a way out of this so
tonight the b5 would just be trading
pieces night b5 Knight takes pawn takes
yes the b3 okay so then it's like Boop
we probably want to take it back right
and the Bishop to e7 okay so he's out of
the he's out of the pawn fork so look at
what we got we just play d5 like we just
pawned for Q and now he played nine a5
thinking he's he's tricking us so Bishop
to b3 doesn't work because we can trade
it out Bishop to b5 check doesn't work
as the Bishop can retreat as anybody
ever heard the expression Knights on the
rim or grim okay that's good okay well
the reason why is because grim it means
you have a very dark future it's like
you got no hope you're done you're in a
black hole where can that neck go
know where that's the correct answer he
can go nowhere a septum c4 right
excellent retreat the Bishop to e2 and
now he's got to save his bishop right so
he's like okay I saved my bishop now
what do we do to win that piece b4
excellent and now the knight has nowhere
to go he's got a grim existence okay so
he just goes back and now we take bishop
takes so now he's got two guys on our
pawn we protect it so now you decide to
get a King side attack rolling okay
Knight - there all right
you think we're afraid of this King side
attack right now anybody afraid now we
can just do our own thing b5 Bishop back
Knight attacks the Queen so he moves it
back alright so we solidify our post and
now black plays the unusual move Knight
takes H - okay so is that a good idea
for black to be sacrificing pieces to
get out our King at this moment no the
reason is because all those other people
are just sitting on the back row doing
nothing they're not really in a position
to really check the King and do him any
danger he actually does take with the
King because he's not afraid of Queen
check because the knight would take it
so when you're down material and nobody
is around your king that's not a good
time to sacrifice pieces all right so
now he gets a little little steam going
here so g5 continuing with is a big
attack so Knight f6 check King there
Bishop takes
and now each six now it's time to put
down the hammer here okay so check all
right well you have a lot of checks you
don't even realize how many checks you
have I bet you have any idea how many
checks you have so when you say check it
could be one of like eight checks right
now Knight to d5 check that's the best
one the second best one is Knight the g8
check but Knight to d5 check is the best
okay because it's a double check and
when a kings in the double check the
only thing the only way you can get out
of a double check is the movies King
right because if he captures one thing
he's still in the check from the other
thing right if you blacks one check with
the infamous f6 he's still in the other
check so he's got to move his king all
right and then boink
we got your queen and now now this is
the only time white messes up in the
game he's got a mate a mate in a three
and he misses it so can anybody do
better than Neil here and find the mate
and three Queen to f7 we might be on to
something we might be on to something
all right whatever Wilma King there
ha there you go checkmate alright
alright the way he plays Queen to f5
check King back alright so he plays
Queen there and so he just brings that
so he gets the rook c6 gets the other
rook gets the Queen get the fish up and
it's pretty much falling apart for him
and King to g1 threatening rook takes
pawn you can't do really anything about
it
so after rook takes pawn check the only
move he could play now is f6 and how
would we finish black off here not quite
because these guys got two ways out now
so let's not do that
well how's that close enough
you got to seal the deal when you're
when you're at the end of a game you
gentlemen should be rushing you know
before you think about football players
when they're about to win a game right
they're like yeah all right
that's how you got to be and say oh
close enough as now it's not close
enough
let's finish them Queen d6 all right
that's looking pretty good
rook to f8 yeah it doesn't matter if I
go here rook f8 still will seal the deal
okay
ko all right good job tonight everybody
thank you